[Music]
hello time then for the press preview
it's our first look at the front pages
and tonight joining me to see what's
making the headlines of the director of
the john smith center at the university
of glasgow kezia dugdale and pr
consultant alex dean they'll be with us
from now until just before midnight chat
to them in a second after we've had a
look at those front pages
for you we're going to start with the ft
according to the paper official figures
showing that real terms wages are
falling at their fastest rate for 20
years likely means inflation won't come
under control anytime soon and will
increase the pressure of the cost of
living crisis
british workers need more graft says liz
trust that's on the guardian front page
after the emergence of that
controversial audio clip this evening
while express has her attacking eu
bosses for breaking a research agreement
to punish the uk over brexit
the metro hears that ryanair intends to
lay on extra flights out of stansted
airport because the airline's boss
michael o'leary is frustrated at
heathrow airport extending its daily
passenger limit through the october
half-term holidays
the former prime minister tony blair has
called on the government to ensure every
adult gets the upcoming omicron booster
jab that's according to the i
the mail reports that cyclists could
soon be forced to have number plates and
insurance under a radical shake-up of
the road laws
the telegraph hears from a former
immigration minister who says theresa
may's modern slavery law is mainly to
blame for the number of illegal
immigrants who avoid deportation
the star reports on ryan giggs's
testimony at his trial for assault he
denies all the charges same story in
fact on the front of the daily mirror
and the sun shines light on pop idol
stars darius dinesh's very sad death
uh don't forget you can scan the qr code
on screen at any time join the program
and you'll be able to check out the
front pages of tomorrow's papers while
you watch us discussing them and kezia
and alex are with me now to do just that
great to see you uh thanks for joining
us this evening kezia why don't you kick
things off we'll start with the the cost
of living crisis and uh
yet more uh bad news with this record
fall in wages
yes i'm afraid so so this story comes
off the back of new office national
statistics data that shows in the three
months leading to june the value of
wages fell by three percent in real
terms that's the biggest fall in 20
years that's led for the resolution
foundation to say that it's going to
take us back to a cost of living squeeze
that feels like 1976 1977. so more bad
economic news interestingly though
there's some in real detail on this that
might surprise you for example they also
report that it's leading to lots of
people over the age of 65 returning to
the labour market an additional 180 000
over 65 year olds seeking to work i
think that's a clear sign as any we've
had so far that cost of living crisis is
really biting
yeah alex the the figures show that
average wages rose 4.7 between april and
june but of course that's been outpaced
by inflation so the real value of pay
fell
by three percent so i suppose everyone
will be looking to see what happens over
the next few months to inflation
that's right jonathan and i think too
that that 4.7 rise in wages is more than
we would normally see so the employers
are trying uh to keep up but the trouble
with inflation is even higher we knew
that this was coming didn't we this has
been projected and foreseen for some
time and i think it does two things
immediately in uh terms of politics
today the first obviously putting
pressure on the two candidates for the
leadership of the conservative party and
therefore to be prime minister to
clarify their economic plans and to say
whether or not they
are inflationary and if so how they deal
with it and the second is really put
into sharp focus the commitments about
things that government can do quickly
even if as a matter of fact they are not
the most substantive in their effect
like the green uh levy on energy bills
that's very hard to maintain no matter
what your position was on climate change
and in the long term it's going to be
very hard for people facing these kinds
of squeezes to say government should
still be taking that kind of money from
people as we go into what is also
projected to be a pretty tough winter
yeah um because you're just looking at
the front of the times in fact we know
those hustings uh this evening in uh in
scotland rishi sunak turns on rival over
moral duty to ease bills um the former
chancellor uh insisting uh that if liv's
trust becomes um prime minister millions
will will face poverty and what have you
made of both contenders uh
uh bids to solve the crisis
well of course they're talking in that
context about energy costs which aren't
factored into these figures that we're
talking about just now around the cost
of living crisis because that only leads
us up till june so there's no doubt that
it's going to get substantially worse
this winter and the cost of living
crisis and the energy bills in
particular have been a key focus of the
conservative leadership contest
with neither candidate really having a
plan that meets the size of the
challenge ahead talking about energy
bills in excess of four thousand pounds
for a year some reports saying it could
be high as five yet these leadership
contenders are talking about handouts
and using pejorative terms like handouts
around the 400 pound mark so that's
really not going to make a difference
the majority of people who are really
going to feel the bite of those
increased energy bills yeah alex i don't
know if you managed to to watch the
hustings this evening or or read much of
what was said
but what are you making of where the two
candidates stand
well the thing is when it looks like
you've got a clear leader and whatever
you think of these candidates it does
seem like liz truss is firmly in the
lead it tempts the underdog to go to
further extremes to try and shake the
dial and move things in his or her favor
and this is an example of that because
this is clearly a kind of pretty robust
would be the polite way of putting in it
attack from one of the rivals against
the other and my i suppose my first
point is this the conservative party
with these months-long kind of blue on
blue attacks within its own ranks is
generating future billboards for the
labour party here is a former chancellor
of the exchequer saying some very
unpleasant things about the person very
likely to become our prime minister i
think in retrospect people will be
saying did we really need months long
for the membership do the membership
really need that much longer to make up
their minds that our members of
parliament do and i anticipate one
action coming out of this is going to be
shortening any uh future leadership
contest timetable yeah i mean that's the
issue isn't it casually that for every
week that goes by is another week where
the crisis isn't solved
well well that's true and i've got some
some sympathy with what alex says but at
the same time this has to be a thorough
and democratic process it's only members
of the conservative party that are going
to choose the next prime minister unless
of course they call a general election
which feels highly unlikely so we should
have an extended time to scrutinise
their policies and look at what they
stand for but when i look at the detail
of their policies i don't think either
are really rising to the challenge the
story in the front of the ft also
includes a quote that suggests that
interest rates and will have to go up
again in september potentially by 0.5
percent rising to 3 by the end of the
year that will panic md right now who's
looking at getting a mortgage it will be
further economic was right through the
winter this is going to dominate the
political weather for some time to come
and back and forth between the
conservative candidates is i'm afraid
exactly what we need to shake out who
stands for what and what they're going
to do for us
yeah except the one point the one point
on that is of course interests have been
interest rates have been historically
lows for a long time and for everyone
that has a concern on their mortgage on
the one hand would you rightly point to
there are savers who are not getting the
kind of returns that they might like to
have in in their retirements and
particularly these lots of less well-off
people who are depending on their
pensions which in turn are invested in
things so interest rate rises are not
all bad they can actually not just bring
an economy's temperature down a bit they
can bring real rewards to people too
okay let's move on to the front of the
guardian uh pippa carrera the political
editor um kicking off her new job
in style with this scoop liz truss
condemning british workers for what she
said
is a lack of graft and also british
workers lacking the skill and
application of uh those from abroad that
really fascinating comments made uh not
recently but a few years ago cause yeah
what did you what did you make of this
well this is true to form uh for liz
trust because it wasn't so long ago that
we were recounting paragraphs in a book
that she jointly written with some other
leading conservatives where she called
everett's work the worst idlers so i'm
afraid it's just another example of her
showing what she really thinks and it
will play well i think probably on
amongst the conservative base who as
we've just discussed are voting in this
contest it won't play well in the
country and i think in particular it's a
bad news story for those people who left
voting the labour party for generations
to vote conservative perhaps for the
first time in so many of those red wall
seats that defined the last general
election so it might work on the floor
of these hustings but it'll cause
jitters and conservative hq
yeah i mean alex will it will it be that
damaging really because it's not
necessarily going to affect uh the vote
for the for the leadership it could have
more of an effect uh when a general
election comes around but by then um the
public may have forgotten about this
yeah i i dare say people running
campaigns think let's cross that bridge
when we come to it but of course this
wasn't a deliberately planned uh
leak or or announcement from the trust
campaign this was a paper creator off to
a big bang with her new
role and good for her for a scoop but
kesley and i do agree actually this is
not um out of tune with what we've heard
from liz trust uh for a long time and
she may phrase it and couch it in
different ways sometimes she's very fond
rightly of pointing out the fact we've
got a productivity problem in this
country that british workers
productivity is lower than our peers but
kazia is right there the book britannia
and change is out there authors took
joint responsibility for it the
candidate that i support to be our prime
minister liz trust has said for some
time the british workers need to do more
and i think also it's true this won't
really hurt her amongst conservative
party voters i think lots of people have
thought that for some time so all in all
whilst it's good news all around i
suppose good news for the journalists
getting a scoop good news for liz trust
and in a few years time if it comes to
an election i don't think it's going to
be in the forefront of people's minds
yeah she described the most the worst
idlers in the world i think didn't she
and very uh very quickly just 30 seconds
to go quick look at the front of the
metro casio ryanair to the
rescue yes this is michael larry and
taking a grab and having a go at what he
describes as hopeless heathrow he's
going to ensure that more flights leave
instead from stansted this coming
october so people can get more of a
holiday in the time that comes this is
down to the fact that stan said have
done a better job of retaining so many
of their ground staff they've not had
the same labour market problems that
have really troubled heathrow throughout
the summer
very quick thought alex michael o'leary
on the front of the paper as well good
publicity fame
brilliant pr what a headline no dream of
that sort of thing the man knows how to
catch the mood at the moment doesn't he
yeah uh and you would know as a pr
consultant okay thank you both we'll
speak again in a moment coming up in a
minute is teresa may's asylum policy to
blame for fewer deportations in recent
times one former minister thinks so
we'll discuss that next
[Music]
alex and kezia still with us discussing
tomorrow's papers uh front page of the
daily telegraph alex why don't you kick
things off uh for this part modern
slavery law is biggest loophole for
migrants
yeah we were talking about blue on blue
earlier and this is a different kind of
blue and blue eye spaces chris philp the
former minister responsible for
immigration
claiming that theresa may's modern
slavery uh reforms which are meant to
help people who've been you know forced
into slavery and and used you know
garage for courts and
made to work in menial jobs and for
inappropriate pay or here or abroad uh
could find asylum and can find a
permanent place to stay in the united
kingdom is being widely abused
he claims specifically that not only is
it much easier to claim that you have
been
as a victim of slavery than it is to
claim other um conditions and that the
hurdles are very low there's basically
no burden of proof to demonstrate that
you've been a victim of slavery to get
that protection he also claims that
people who've been coming to this
country making one claim or other that
hasn't been working and then switching
to a claim of slavery when they realize
that they haven't been making headway i
mean either way it's a real headache for
the home office to have people making
these points but if he's right it's
really got to stop and you'll see in the
piece too that pretty patel has promised
a clamp down the problem with all of
these internal arguments about what the
tory pie has been getting wrong is the
natural question from people is well why
haven't you done it already and that
quick question will no doubt be
forthcoming because of this story too
cassie
i think this is a really astonishing and
quite striking story because you know
it's been referred to as theresa may's
modern slavery act she's not somebody
known as being particularly liberal or
soft on immigration by any stretch of
the imagination she was the original
architect of the hostile environment she
was the person who uh sponsored go home
vans during her time of being home
secretary and here she is being accused
of basically being a lefty liberal when
it comes to these immigration issues
we're talking here about people who are
being exploited
for labor they are potentially victims
of being trafficked for sex they are
very vulnerable people that could even
be in domestic servitude and yet we're
being told that they are the people who
need to provide evidence of what's
happened to them in order to stay in
this country there's a really quite
astonishing story that'll stick in the
throat of a lot of people that want
there to be immigration controls want
there to be a strong and robust system
but still for there to be legal routes
for people who are facing some of the
most
extreme destitution to make a life in
this country and to flee horrible
circumstances like this because you
can't mean that they don't need to have
any proof do you
well i'm just wondering how you can
expect them to have proof you know how
do you prove that you're being exploited
when you have nothing and you're utterly
destitute and you've been under the in
circumstances and you know existence
that many of the people who are being
exploited and for these purposes face i
i just think there needs to be a little
bit of reality check here that about
what exactly the burden of proof is and
where it lies you're asking vulnerable
people to to prove something that for
them is probably now impossible it's
just utterly heartless and it's
astonishing to see a conservative figure
basically accuse theresa may of not
being strong enough on immigration okay
but having a plausible account that can
uh be from which inferences can be drawn
might be a reasonable start but you
began by your answer by suggesting that
these people are victims of slavery so
you assume that it is
automatically true i mean that would
mean that someone could simply come to
this country from anywhere say i am a
victim of slavery and with no more ado
have permanent right to remain in the
united kingdom under our asylum laws but
that can't be right can it okay i'll
tell you what we can talk we're out of
time but we will talk more um in a few
minutes uh time on that story uh if you
wish and if you choose it from the
papers we can discuss it further but for
now we must leave it